ما سالنا للعرب تحديدا في مصر كيف
تتعاملون مع ابنكم في حال وجود بوادر
للسمنه شراها في تناول الاكل
[موسيقى]
اكيد هبدا امنع عنه الزيوت والسمنه
والحاجات المهدرجه وكده واكله خضار
وبروتينات ببدا ان انا اقلل معه ان هو
الاكلات اللي هي بتزود له السمنه ديت يعني
ما بخليهوش ان هو حاجات شيكولاتات الحاجات
الشيبسي الكلام ده وده لازم ان انا باعوده
له من الاول
نعملها ان انا ودي نادي مثلا يلعب فيه او
ان انا امنعوا عن الاكلات اللي بتبقى سهله
زي مثلا الفشار او الشيبسي وممكن ابدلها
بثمره او اي حاجه من الخضروات اللي بتبقى
مفيده للجسم غذائي سليم همم ابعد عن مثلا
الدهون الفاست فود لازم يلعب رياضه يمشي
على نظام غذائي سليم او نظام غذائي صحي
علشان برده هو الطفل نفسه في الوقت ده لما
يبقى عنده سنه مفرطه لما يكبر يبقى قدامه
عقبات كثير
اقدر مخليهوش ان هو ياكل اكل كثير عشان
يلعب رياضه ويعرف يتمرن يبطل اكل الشارع
وحش جدا بيسبب سنه جامده جدا وغير كده
كمان السهر
العادات اللي هي مش كويسه اللي بتسبب في
ده مثلا زي
المشروبات الغازيه
[موسيقى]